hi there Steve coffin here today I want
to talk about something that I consider
to be the sort of magic ingredient of
language learning and that is confidence
all right no confidence doesn't mean
normally when people think of confidence
connected with language learning they
think of you know the confidence to
speak there you know that there's so
many people who are too shy to speak and
so it tell me that's not the important
confidence because even in in ordinary
life in our own language some people are
more confident than others that someone
might be very confident about their
ability in a language and in fact
they're not very good but they don't
mind so there they just blurt out
whatever they have and make mistakes
which is fine which is good but other
people prefer not to do that other
people prefer to waive and then they may
speak more carefully with a little bit
less confidence that doesn't mean they
can't learn the language I mean you can
learn the language not speaking at all
and at some point you start speaking so
the confidence to speak the confidence
to use the language to me is not the the
important kind of confidence it's nice
to have that confidence and I certainly
encourage people to speak and at some
point to speak a lot because that's the
only way you're gonna get good at
speaking is to speak a lot but the
important confidence is is that sense
that you know can I learn this is the
confidence and I was thinking about this
because there's there have been a number
of tweets and reports about you know as
you get older you can't learn and then I
sort of said well no you know I'm in my
70s now and I'm still learning and then
their answer saying yes but here's this
research that shows that our brain
activity cognitive abilities decline
with age as I'm here I am struggling
with Arabic and it's been five months
more than five months and I still have
trouble I confuse certain Arabic letters
and I seem to be forgetting words I say
geez you know am I getting older now am
I am I not able to learn this language
and then I say well no
just think back five months ago when I
started I thought that I will never
learn to read the Arabic writing system
because there were four different forms
of each each symbol each letter and
there's no you know consonants or like
hardly any and stuff so yeah I look back
to where I was and Here I am five months
later actually I'm doing quite well and
I mean I'm reading some fairly difficult
stuff granted with the help of of you
know link and stuff like that I'm
plowing my way through SML I've gone
through all 76 lessons once for forget
all the words I'm going back through now
around 45 46 going through it again I am
getting somewhere
so yes I am confident that I can learn
Arabic whether my brain cells have
slowed down or my cognitive ability is
not what it was when I was 20 is kind of
irrelevant it's like this discussion
about whether some people are better
than others at learning or whether kids
are better or older people are better it
really doesn't matter as long as you can
learn you know some people will learn
faster and some people slower and some
people will be better at some aspects of
the language and others will be better
at other aspects so it doesn't matter so
yeah I am confident that I will learn
Arabic however long it takes me and I'm
enjoying it so that but that confidence
that you can get there is extremely
important it's also important to be
confident that it's worthwhile that that
you are doing something that is
important that matters that is gonna be
beneficial to you in some personal way
because you don't want to be doing
something and then second-guessing jeez
is it really you know for example when I
tell people that I'm learning Arabic
they look at me as if I'm a lunatic you
know a like why would you why would you
take that on and be you speak all these
other languages is now you're gonna have
to neglect these languages to learn
Arabic why are you doing it but then
again you know as I you know listen to
or read these stories in Arabic Arab
people speaking to each other
about things that are related to their
culture or part of their daily life and
I'm able to understand it and the other
day there was a tweet by someone that I
follow on Twitter and it had a headline
from an Egyptian newspaper and I was
able to read it alone I missed the odd
word a--basically I was able to read it
and I get great satisfaction so yeah I'm
confident that it is worth my while to
be learning of course the other
confidence is are you confident that the
way you are learning the method you're
using is effective is this the best way
to learn here again that becomes very
subjective I enjoy the way I learn I
know that there are inefficiencies I
know for example that I tend to listen
to you know I've got these various
sources or resources that I'm using I've
got them on my iPhone so I will tend to
listen if I'm in the car for half an
hour for an hour a day I'll be listening
through lots of these stories and I miss
a lot of words if I were trying to be
efficient I would probably focus on one
story a little more listen to it don't
understand go right back and read it
again go back and listen again so that I
would get more concentration but
realistically that's not how my day
develops the way my day develops is I go
somewhere in my car doesn't do half an
hour and then I come back I listen to
half an hour then I sit down and maybe
spend another 20 minutes half an hour on
my computer so these activities are
disjointed so I recognize that the way
I'm learning is perhaps not the most
efficient way but it's it's a way that
conforms to my other activities daily
activities it's a way that makes sense
for me it's not as efficient as it could
be but I'm confident that it's it's
essentially gonna get me to my
destination so I think it is important
that that we be confident that we can
learn the language that it's worth while
doing so and that the method we are
using is appropriate and if we have
those three
kinds of confidences you know then we
will learn we will acquire words we will
enjoy the language and at some point we
will speak and some will speak earlier
and some will speak later and some was
beat with more confidence than some will
speak with less confidence but that
confidence to speak to my mind in the
long run
ever think about learning the language
that confidence to speak is less
important than this confidence that you
can achieve your goal that you're doing
it the right way and that it's
worthwhile doing so there are some
thoughts on confidence so I am confident
that I can learn the learn Arabic I'm
and other languages that are going to
learn I'm not so confident that my
cognitive powers are you know not worse
than they were when I was 20 years old
but I don't care okay thank you for
listening bye for now
[Music]